Oil.
Venezuela's greatest natural resource, but also its greatest curse.
Oil kept Maduro's predecessor, Hugo Chavez, afloat for a decade before the price fell dramatically in 2008.
After Chavez's death in 2013,
Nicolas Maduro became president. He continued the Chavez government's economic policies, but oil prices fell dramatically again in 2014.
For years, the low price of oil has put a strain on the Venezuelan economy.
To help it recover, Maduro introduced the Petro in February 2018, a cryptocurrency pegged to the price of oil.
But in September 2018, the petrol tanked too. In August 2018, Maduro announced a
3000 percent hike in the minimum wage to quell unrest over inflation and shortages.
But by December last year inflation hit a whopping 1.7 million percent.
The Bloomberg News Agency came up with the Cafe con Leche index.
The price of a cup of coffee reached 2 million bolivars in June of 2018 – at the time, around 50 US cents.
Maduro revalued the national currency, the bolivar,
slashing five zeros that brought the cost of a cup of coffee down to 20 bolivars.
But by the start of 2019, the price again soared
to 1.4 million of the new bolivars. That's equal to 140 million old bolivars.
People run to buy groceries as soon as they get paid before their salary loses its value.
That's if they can even find food.
Venezuelans are tired of shortages and inflation.
More than three million of them have left the country in recent years fleeing mainly to Colombia.
But the anger is growing among those who have stayed.